hey this is presh talwalkar
mr white mr blue mr brown and mr pink
are at a restaurant
mr pink said
i can't believe it the boss gave us
names that match our shirt colors but no
one got the same name as their own shirt
color
my name is terrible
who cares what anyone's name is
said the person in the blue shirt
yeah that's easy for you to say you have
a cool sounding name
maybe if the cleaners hadn't messed up
my dark colored shirts i would have worn
a different shirt and gotten a better
name
mr pink replied
yeah i don't like my name either said mr
brown
what is the color of each person's shirt
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
let's analyze the statements that we
were given
we know that there are four different
people who are at a restaurant
mr pink explains
that they were given names that match
their shirt colors
so the shirts will be the same colors as
their names
but no one got the same name as their
own shirt color
in our logical grid this means we can
eliminate the entries along the diagonal
mr white is not wearing a white shirt mr
blue is not wearing a blue shirt mr
brown is not wearing a brown shirt and
mr pink is not wearing a pink shirt
who cares what anyone's name is said the
person in the blue shirt
this implies that the person in the blue
shirt is not mr pink
so we can eliminate that mr pink is
wearing a blue shirt
when mr pink replies he says that his
cleaners messed up his dark colored
shirts
this means he was not wearing a brown
colored shirt either
by process of elimination that means mr
pink was wearing a white shirt
furthermore since each person is wearing
a different colored shirt that means no
one else is wearing a white shirt
we have one more statement from mr brown
who says he doesn't like his name either
in contrast to the person in the blue
shirt who doesn't care what anyone's
name is
this implies that mr brown is not
wearing a blue shirt
by process of elimination this means mr
brown is wearing a pink shirt
and mr white is wearing a blue shirt
so we can eliminate that anyone else is
wearing these shirt colors and that
leaves that mr blue is wearing a brown
shirt so this very last statement brings
it all together and we can figure out
that mr white is wearing a blue shirt mr
blue is wearing a brown shirt mr brown
is wearing a pink shirt and mr pink is
wearing a white shirt
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description